Dallas good morning thanks for joining
us what were your thoughts when you
first heard the tebow was going to hold
this workout uh the first initial
thought I guess is this sec getting that
boring to him um I don't know why he
would have come out of the woodworks to
put himself on this sort of stage if you
will it's a very lonely stage but then
you remember and you realize who Tim
Tebow's a human being the competitor is
and you do a little you do a little
searching you do a little homework and
you find out this is a dream he's been
pursuing for the better part of a year
he's done his due diligence and
searching out finding out people he
feels can can let me down tutelage and
get him to the point he feels he can
actually put something like this
together and that happened and so I
think like everybody when you hear the
name Tim Tebow synonymous with sports
here in America at this point you you
open your eyes and like any GM would yet
you answer the phone call on a hidden
gem you put eyes on him and so I think
everybody who was at the workout
yesterday is coming from that school of
thought where it is Tim Tebow let's see
what we got so my initial reaction was
come on really you think you're just
gonna put down the pigskin put down the
microphone and pick up big-league
caliber skill set to get you to like
that was my initial thought and you know
I i left with not not a very with a
fairly similar taste in my mouth your
expectations yesterday and then the end
results how different were they armed
not far off uh I unless you've been
under a rock I didn't need to know that
tim tebow could run I didn't need to see
the 60 to understand the tebow could
move for a man his size I didn't need to
see the 430 foot tape measure shots he
hit during BP to know that he was strong
I didn't need to see that what I did
want to see is how well he was able to
use his feet and get himself in position
in the outfield was he able to track a
ball did he know how to take a correct
angle
he get behind a ball could he pivot his
hips could he play through a ball and
make a strong throw and the answer to
that was no the froze were on a 20 to 80
scale of my opinion the arm strength out
of 40 just below average we factor in
the ability to get to a bag accurately
that was a struggle for him at one point
in time he fell in the outfield on the
warning track and I was taken aback by
that when you consider the footwork
required to play the position of
quarterback whether it be at the
collegiate level or the NFL but then you
have to remind yourself that Tim Tebow
was not the prototypical quarterback at
the collegiate level or the NFL level
this is a man who for lack of a better
term outmuscled the game for the most
part of his career think about baseball
Dan you can outmuscle this game it
doesn't care how big you are how strong
you are how tall you are how fast you
are if you can't apply any of those
skills to the skill set required to
achieve success in the game of baseball
you're done you don't even get to start
what kind of pitches would you throw him
well it all depends on what side of the
tebow camp I was on if I was receding
you're facing him you're you're actually
facing after you know he hit fast balls
but if you were actually facing him what
would download right make him if I face
Tim Tebow he's going to get my 85 287 a
two-seamer running in on the hands
probably somewhere in the upper echelon
of the strike zone and then he's going
to get the sliders down in a way because
he hasn't seen one since he's 16 and
he's not going to have a chance to get
to it that's just going to be that's
just the truth that's that's the nuts
and bolts of the situation you run him
in but you put him in that proverbial
rocking chair hard in soft away his role
a wrinkle on them thanks for coming out
I feel like a team would want to be if
I'm a team then let's say you're the
Padres or you're the Marlins why not
give him a flier in the minor leagues or
I you know I would I would test him and
see do you want to go to the Fall League
you know and play their know how
committed are you because to me I
thought it was a marketing business plan
yesterday and really had nothing to do
with playing Major League Baseball
and I would completely disagree with
that only because you do have to
consider the pay cut that tebow is going
to take here in his attempt to get to
the major leagues you're thinking about
Italy in my opinion at least a two year
process throughout the minor leagues to
polish these rough edges to make him
presentable no I don't think he's going
to do it dallas I'm saying if I'm a team
I would use it i would use him for the
marketing part of this I even have Tim
Tebow batting practice night and just go
out and work it you know take back your
if you're yeah if your key if you're a
team what you do is you take the flyer
on him you maybe put them in instruct to
see how that goes and you tell them hey
instructs went well or didn't go well
we've got some things to work on we'll
see you in bit ly camp next year that's
the route you take if your big league
team because then what happens is you're
able to run Tim Tebow out there in a Tim
Tebow major league jersey authenticated
by Major League Baseball and now you've
got yourself a marketing ploy now you
can sell Tim Tebow major league baseball
jerseys that's the route they would take
and the unfortunate side of the business
of baseball is you're absolutely right
in my opinion there's probably more than
one team who is not only willing but
ready to make that sort of move and
that's that's unfortunate but don't you
think this was a marketing plan by Tebow
and his people the assigned the adidas
deal it's a multi-year deal you go out
you gotta d dis on head to toe and
you're in front of people scouts you're
not going to make a team but instead of
having a press conference to announce
your signing with adidas or having a
press release you put out an
instructional video there well and I
think to their to their defense to the
to the defense of Tebow's camp they made
every effort to not allow any sort of
live streaming live taping which would
have been obviously given him that that
billboard of a platform to just trot out
there and and you know let's call a
spade a spade it's the first time in a
workout I've seen three different
wardrobe changes so there were a couple
different pairs of cleats there were you
know he he had his throw to bases shirt
on he had his run the bases shirt on yet
as BP shirt on 'edit live EP shirt on so
I can understand that
but but realistically when when when it
came down to us that this was happening
you know the request was look we want to
make this as authentic as possible for
Tim it's not realistic that there would
ever be a trial with just one individual
that he would be used to the combine is
completely different setting so when you
factor in them wanting to sort of coal
all the attention and also the fact that
tebow has has said I'm willing to make
this dedication I don't think it was the
marketing ploy that probably a lot of
people thought it was initially yeah
well then I'm I'm in the minority how do
I know he's serious after this uh you
know he's serious after this when he is
told that he doesn't have a shot and he
continues to grind he's he's serious
about this after he is told you're going
to spring training it's going to be
minor league spring training you're
going to go to extended spring training
which means you're going to sit out here
in Arizona or Florida in the sweltering
summer heat with kids who are 17 18
years old throw in 100 miles an hour
they have no idea where it's going and
you get to eat peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches with these kids every single
day at the camp because that's what that
lifestyle offers you this is not a
glorious lifestyle it's not a glamorous
lifestyle your noses to the grindstone
you're on a field out in the middle of a
desert or a swamp for 14 hours a day
trying to get it right and that's
nothing he's afraid of there's no doubt
about that let's not question this man's
work ethic in being around a group of
young kids would be outstanding at the
very least just to show them how to do
it the question is does he know how to
do it over a course of 142 this is a
game built on failure and when you step
up to the plate and you failed seven
times out of 10 you get to go to the
Hall of Fame it's how you react when you
failed nine out of ten times can you
take that back up to the plate the next
time with the same confidence you did
when you square it up under center at
the goal line make a jump passes is it
there your appearance was better than
his workout let me put it that way down
you were really good today well thanks
dad thanks for having my buddy thank you
that's a dallas braden former pitcher
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you